Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonsoir.
Je ne vous apprendrai rien si je vous dis
que les humains font partie
de la communauté des rampants.
Pourtant, on a toujours rêvé de voler.
Certains de vos illustres prédécesseurs
l’ont d’abord imaginé.
Puis quelques aventuriers s’y sont risqués
avec plus ou moins de succès.
Les premiers sauts de puce.
Puis, ils y sont vraiment arrivés.
Puis, on s’est rendu compte
qu’on pouvait tirer un certain nombre
d’avantages sociétaux
en reliant les continents.
Des avantages militaires dans
la Deuxième guerre mondiale.
Et puis, après la Deuxième guerre
mondiale, l’avènement du transport aérien,
avec un fameux avion
de l’industrie toulousaine.
Puis le cargo qui a permis
des services de transport.
Et enfin l’aviation commerciale
qui s’est répandue
et qui aujourd’hui offre
autant de services
dont très peu de personnes
seraient prêtes à se passer.
Pourtant les experts
du GIEC sont formels :
aujourd’hui, il y a urgence,
si on ne veut pas que
ce soit le rêve d’Icare.
Pas simplement le rêve d'Icare
qui fasse ça, mais l'homme.
Il est plus qu'urgent de se transformer.
C’est vrai pour toutes
les activités humaines
et en particulier pour l’aéronautique.
Se transformer,
Qu’est-ce que ça veut dire globalement,
dans la situation dans laquelle
est le monde ?
C’est se transformer ou disparaître.
De ce point de vue-là,
l’histoire est assez éloquente.
Nos illustres ancêtres Néandertalis
s’étaient bien adaptés à leur milieu,
et à des changements d’environnement,
des changements de climat particuliers,
alors qu’il avait affronté
des grands froids,
des changements de faune et de flore,
l’ont soumis à la maladie.
Et puis moins bien adapté,
moins intelligent
que son cousin
Sapiens, qui maîtrisait l’outil,
fait disparaître Néandertalis.
Plus proche de nous,
les Mayas nous enseignent beaucoup
sur l’emballement d’une société humaine
qui ne prend pas compte
de son environnement
et qui s’emballe.
Déforestation, érosion,
malnutrition, famine, maladies.
Quelques mauvaises récoltes liées
à des changements climatiques
et c’est toute la société qui s’effondre
alors qu’elle était au pinacle
des sociétés américaines.
Les entreprises,
le modèle économique lui-même,
est basé sur le principe de l’adaptation.
Innover pour une entreprise est
la condition de la survie.
Or, l’innovation en soi
est une forme d’adaptation.
On différencie généralement deux façons
pour une entreprise de s’adapter.
Soit une adaptation réactive
à un changement de l’environnement.
L’environnement pouvant
être la compétition
ou les conditions
dans lesquelles l’entreprise opère.
Dans ces cas-là, l’adaptation
correspond à changer
les comportements de l’entreprise
et les produits,
pour être davantage en adéquation
avec l’environnement.
Je pense que vous vous souvenez tous en
2020, un aéroport, ça ressemblait à ça.
L’aéronautique a dû évidemment
s’adapter en réaction
à ces changements environnementaux.
Une pandémie mondiale : plus de trafic.
S’adapter en réaction
pour pouvoir ensuite repartir
une fois que la pandémie est heureusement
passée et que le trafic a repris.
Il existe une deuxième façon
de s’adapter pour une entreprise.
C’est une adaptation
qu’on appelle de contrôle,
où finalement l’entreprise change
les règles concurrentielles
à son avantage.
Avant 2007, un téléphone portable,
ça ressemble à ça.
Je sais que dans la salle
il y en a beaucoup qui n’ont pas connu,
mais en 2007, un certain
Steve Jobs arrive et dit :
« Non, Un téléphone portable,
ça doit ressembler à ça.»
Bon, à cette époque, je travaillais
pour non pas Nokia,
mais Motorola qui n’avait pas vu
venir le changement.
Surtout, c’était un changement
qui les avait dépassés.
Aujourd'hui, ces deux entreprises
ont disparu.
Les marques sont restées,
mais les entreprises ont disparu.
L’aéronautique aujourd’hui est face
à un triple changement de paradigme.
D’abord l’urgence climatique, on l’a vu,
mais également le renchérissement
des ressources fossiles
qui servent évidemment
de combustible pour cette industrie,
et à terme, leur disparition.
Et puis, une troisième tendance,
finalement le niveau de vie
mondial, fait qu’aujourd’hui,
de plus en plus de personnes
dans le monde aspirent à voler
et donc finalement,
il y a une hausse du trafic.
On comprend bien que sans transformation,
il sera impossible de remplir
ces trois objectifs.
Se transformer, pour l’aéronautique,
ça passe par quoi ?
Comme pour tous les modes de transport
et comme toutes les activités humaines
d’une façon générale,
ça passera d’abord par
des transformations de la société.
Donc, la société doit se donner des
objectifs entre les différentes modalités
et également donner la possibilité
aux différentes modalités de transport
ou de production d’électricité,
d’usage en général,
donner les modalités et la possibilité de
se transformer vers de la décarbonation,
puisque c’est l’objectif
numéro un, aujourd’hui.
À ce titre, pour ce qui concerne
le secteur aéronautique,
la directive ReFuel EU,
avec des quotas carbones
et des échanges carbone
va renchérir le coût du transport aérien
pour les entreprises de transport
et donc pour les consommateurs
qui sont clients du transport aérien.
L’industrie dans son entièreté,
tout le secteur a de ce fait bien compris
qu’il y avait un changement
d’environnement.
Et pour ne pas se retrouver
comme Nokia ou Motorola,
le secteur dans son ensemble
a adopté une feuille de route
pour une décarbonation à l’horizon 2050,
pour être neutre en carbone.
La nouveauté, c’est que les Nations Unies
aujourd’hui ont suivi cette injonction
et ce sont les États qui sont engagés.
Lors de la dernière assemblée de l’OACI,
l’Organisation des Nations Unies
en charge de l’aviation civile,
les États ont signé un engagement
de neutralité carbone à l’horizon 2050.
Pour l’aéronautique, neutralité carbone
et baisser les émissions,
ça veut dire quoi ?
Ça va passer évidemment
par un mix de solutions.
Il n’y aura pas de baguette magique,
une solution qui résoudra
tous les problèmes.
Parce que, soyons honnêtes, l’aéronautique
depuis 50 ans, ça ronronne un petit peu.
J’ignore s’il y a des ingénieurs
aéronautiques ici,
avec tout mon respect,
depuis le jet à propulsion, on n’a pas
inventé grand-chose dans l’aéronautique.
On a amélioré évidemment.
Mais entre la Caravelle et l’Airbus 350,
ce sont des avions qui sont,
somme toute, assez ressemblants.
Donc, comment cette industrie
va-t-elle pouvoir se transformer
pour pouvoir atteindre cet objectif
de neutralité carbone ?
D’abord, ça passera évidemment
par une exemplarité de l’industrie.
C’est vrai pour toutes les industries,
mais c’est particulièrement vrai
pour l’aéronautique.
On parle de Scope un, Scope deux.
Il faut que l’industrie soit exemplaire
dans l’utilisation des ressources
et dans les émissions
à la fois de carbone dans
les opérations industrielles,
mais également de produits chimiques.
À ce titre, la société civile,
le pouvoir politique aident.
Il existe une réglementation
en Europe appelée REACH
sur les produits de traitement
de surface, en particulier,
qui sont particulièrement compliqués
pour l’aéronautique.
Et l’aéronautique est motrice
pour cette transformation.
Mais aussi et surtout, ça va être
la transformation dans les usages,
dans les produits, le Scope trois.
Les produits aujourd’hui,
c’est le transport aérien.
Pour faire voler un avion,
il faut de l'énergie.
L’énergie, c’est du combustible fossile.
Le combustible fossile, ça génère du CO2,
d’autres composés chimiques
et accessoirement, ça génère aussi
des traînées de condensation
qui, on le verra plus tard,
sont un piège à effet de serre.
Donc les solutions, je vous ai dit,
c'est un mix de solutions.
Et ces solutions, quelles sont-elles ?
Globalement, on va les partager
en quatre familles.
La première famille,
comme je vous l’ai dit, un avion pour
voler, ce n’est pas un planeur,
ça a besoin d’être tracté ou propulsé.
Donc c'est sur l'énergie et la propulsion
qu'on va d'abord travailler.
Donc les énergies fossiles,
on va les retirer progressivement.
Ça ne peut pas se faire
du jour au lendemain.
Et on a identifié
deux sources alternatives.
Avez-vous idée de ces sources ?
Quelqu’un dans la salle ?
L’hydrogène n’est pas une source,
c’est un vecteur.
La biomasse est
la première source évidente.
La biomasse, globalement, c’est du carbone
qui a été capturé dans l’atmosphère
dans un horizon temporel assez récent,
par photosynthèse.
Et donc, il se retrouve aujourd’hui dans
des huiles, industrielles et de cuisson,
des amidons, des sucres, certaines algues,
et qui, par retraitement -
ce sont des chaînes carbonées,
assez proches des hydrocarbures -
fait ce qu’on appelle des biokérosènes,
également appelés SAF en anglais.
Donc ça, c’est la première famille.
La grande difficulté, c’est qu’on a
très peu de biomasse en Europe.
Ça n’aurait aucun sens de l’importer
d’Asie où il y en a beaucoup plus.
Donc ça va être une solution
qui va grossir,
évidemment, il faut créer des nouvelles
filières industrielles.
Mais ça va prendre du temps.
La deuxième source primaire
d’énergie bas carbone, évidemment,
c’est l’électricité.
Évidemment, il faut que ce soit
l’électricité verte, bas carbone,
sinon on a tout perdu.
Et cette électricité, elle va nous servir
à fabriquer de l’hydrogène,
par électrolyse.
Donc ça, on le fait au sol,
sur des infrastructures sol.
Électricité bas carbone,
on fabrique de l’hydrogène.
Cet hydrogène, il peut être soit recombiné
avec du CO2 capturé dans l’atmosphère,
au sol, pour fabriquer un bio-carburant
de synthèse qu’on appelle e-fuel, e-SAF.
Ou alors, cet hydrogène, il va être
embarqué à bord de l’avion
pour servir soit comme carburant mélangé
à de l’oxygène pour un moteur thermique,
soit comme réducteur
dans une réaction d’oxydo-réduction
dans une pile à combustible.
Et donc dans ce cas-là,
on récupère de l’électricité,
la source primaire vecteur hydrogène.
On récupère de l'électricité pour faire
fonctionner des moteurs électriques.
Donc voilà, première famille :
biomasse, électricité.
Ce qu’il faut savoir, c’est que l’Europe
et les pays membres
ont pris des engagements
d’augmentation de la part du SAF.
Les moteurs de dernière génération
sont capables d’embarquer du SAF.
On fait déjà voler des moteurs 100% SAF.
Ceci dit, ce sont des carburants
qui sont un peu plus corrosifs
et qui nécessitent des nouvelles
générations de moteurs.
Pour les moteurs à hydrogène,
ce sont des nouvelles générations
de moteurs.
Deuxième famille :
Comme on va disposer de
davantage d’électricité à bord,
ça ouvre des possibilités pour alléger les
structures pneumatiques et hydrauliques,
qui vont pouvoir être grandement allégées,
car on va remplacer
de la grosse tuyauterie
par des câbles électriques
et un moteur électrique
pour faire tourner tous les systèmes
électriques à bord de l’avion,
le train d’atterrissage, les volets
d’actuation, les systèmes oxygène.
Et puis, il y a des nouveaux composants,
en particulier les thermoplastiques
qui permettent, au-delà des gains
dans la production,
environ de 50 % sur les émissions de CO2
dans le cycle de fabrication,
qui vont permettre des gains de poids
conséquents à bord des avions.
Et du coup, qui dit avion plus léger,
dit avion moins consommateur.
Troisième famille, c'est la data.
Aujourd’hui, le trafic aérien,
le contrôle aérien, les avions eux-mêmes,
sont bourrés de capteurs,
des radars,
des systèmes de vision synthétique,
des capteurs partout sur l’avion,
les avions communiquent entre eux.
Et on va pouvoir améliorer grandement
les opérations au sol et en vol,
avec des nouvelles trajectoires
moins gourmandes en carburant.
Et puis également, cela va nous permettre,
grâce à cette grande quantité de data,
d’éviter les traînées de condensation
dont je vous ai parlé plus tôt.
Ces traînées de condensation
apparaissent sous certaines conditions
de pression, de température,
et comme on connaît beaucoup
mieux la masse d’air
avec l’ensemble des avions
qui volent partout,
on peut prédire les endroits
où elles vont apparaître
et créer des couloirs
permettant de les éviter.
Et puis, si on ne peut pas les éviter,
on a la possibilité d’utiliser
les différentes sources de propulsion
puisqu’on l’a vu,
on a des moteurs électriques
et on a des moteurs thermiques.
D’ailleurs,
compte tenu des énormes quantités
de puissance requises au décollage,
aujourd’hui, on sait faire
voler des avions électriques.
C’est plus compliqué de faire voler
des avions de transport à l’électrique,
aujourd’hui, compte tenu
des densités énergétiques.
On imagine donc assez bien
des solutions mixtes qu’on appelle HEP,
«hybrid electric propulsion»,
qui ressemblent finalement
aux véhicules hybrides terrestres.
Puis la quatrième famille, ce sont
des nouvelles méthodes de production.
Donc là, je dirais, c’est ce que vous
apprenez dans vos écoles,
l’industrie 4.0 basée sur la data,
des cycles qui sont beaucoup plus intégrés
dans l’ensemble de la chaîne de valeur,
au sein de l’ensemble de l’écosystème
de ceux qui contribuent
à fabriquer un avion.
Et ça, ça ouvre
des perspectives nouvelles,
en particulier sur la façon dont
on va faire, par exemple, la maintenance.
Le secteur aéronautique a toujours été
régi par des cycles fixes de maintenance.
Tous des montants d’heures
de vol très fixes,
on change par exemple, les freins,
sans vraiment prendre en considération
l’usure réelle des freins.
Évidemment, les contraintes de sécurité
du vol impose de prendre des marges,
qui font qu’on change des quantités
phénoménales de freins,
très consommateurs d’énergie
dans leur production,
alors qu’ils sont en pleine capacité
de continuer à voler.
Donc grâce à la data, les capteurs,
on va pouvoir augmenter
les périodes d’utilisation
de l’ensemble des matériaux
qui composent les avions.
Voilà, je pense que vous l’aurez compris,
l’aéronautique est un moment de rupture,
de révolution.
Ça fait longtemps qu’on n’a pas connu
une révolution
comme celle dont l’aviation a besoin.
Je dirais qu’aujourd’hui,
vous avez le pouvoir,
vous avez le pouvoir
de changer les choses.
Vous avez le pouvoir
de ne pas être résignés.
Vous avez le pouvoir de mettre l’éducation
humaniste que vous avez reçue,
dans vos écoles, ici à l’INSA,
dans toutes les écoles d’ingénieurs,
au service de la société,
en ingénieurs citoyens
que vous êtes en passe de devenir.
Je conclurai en citant
Antoine de Saint-Exupéry,
une recommandation sans doute
très utile aujourd’hui.
Antoine de Saint-Exupéry nous recommandait
de faire de notre vie un rêve,
et d’un rêve une réalité.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)